[موسيقى] ذاب أكثر من 15 مترًا من الجليد والثلج
خلال السنوات العشر الماضية هنا ، وفي
الواقع لم يعد الممر عبارة عن ممر جليدي
يربط بين نهرين جليديين ،
ولكنه الآن يفصل بين النهرين الجليديين
عن بعضهما البعض ، يخبرك النهر الجليدي
كيف  كانت الظروف المترولوجية على
مدى هذا العام ، ومثل هذا الصيف الدافئ
مثل الصيف الجاف ، إنه في الواقع
شيء سنحصل عليه
كثيرًا أيضًا في المستقبل
[موسيقى]
أجنبية ،
إنها حقًا أبعد من كل شيء قمنا
بقياسه حتى الآن ، فسوف نتعرض
لخسائر كبيرة  أعلى بثلاث مرات من
المتوسط ​​على مدى السنوات العشر الماضية
لأكون صريحًا ، فإن ما لاحظته
هذا العام كان صادمًا حقًا بالنسبة لي
وقد جعلني أشعر بالحزن الشديد كما أنني
خائفة قليلاً من
الأجانب
[موسيقى]
أجنبية